enfin cinéma demain sortie du film de
claude miller la classe de neige un film
récompensé par le prix du jury du
dernier festival de cannes
la classe de neige raconte l'histoire
d'un petit garçon soumis à ses
obsessions venue de drames personnels
pour comprendre l'histoire même de ce
film nous avons provoqué la rencontre
entre claude miller et une thérapeute
une femme habituée à écouter les enfants
reportage au brier de l'air nathalie
gallet le mineur est un cinéaste
singulier qui aiment prendre des risques
et son film la classe de neige en est un
conçu comme un thriller il aborde les
thèmes sombre et dérangeant de l'inceste
et de la pédophilie
pour nous il acceptait de rencontrer
martine nisse thérapeute familial et des
coups aussi ça c'est de toujours des
traces de coups les enfants prennent les
feutres et tape comme ça chaque année
elle suit une centaine d'enfants
maltraités
un chiffre en augmentation constante
j'utilise comme le dessin comme un outil
diagnostic
c'est à dire que l'enfant est envahi par
là
le trouble subie par là notamment la
sexualité génitale adultes puisque je
traite des enfants victimes de
pédophiles ou de parents incestueux et
ils reproduisent pour un élément dans
tous ces dessins ranc ur en cinquième
c'est par son univers fantasmagorique
que la classe de neige nous fait
découvrir nicolas un enfant fragile qui
semble renfermer des souffrances que les
adultes ne parviennent pas à percevoir
la vie de ce gamin là et peupler le
cauchemar de rêverie et de frayeur je
croise on pense très fort chose son
espace on comprend j'avais envie de
raconter d'abord une histoire qui disent
qu'ils diraient que les enfants savent
tout c'est une bombe moi c'est une
intuition que je partage avec beaucoup
d'autres d'ailleurs mais qui savent tout
même si c'est pas avec des mots même si
c'est pas avec un savoir disons
discursif les enfants savent tous que ce
soit le bien où que ce soit le mal
silencieux toujours grave nicolas est en
marche solitaire à la dérive
il parvient pourtant à nous entraîner
dans son aventure il suffira d'un fait
divers atroce survenus dans la région où
il est en classe de neige pour nous
révéler que la réalité est plus terrible
que ses cauchemars
c'est rien c'est vraiment ça qui
demandait à lui qu'est ce que ça voulait
dire nous les élus cas qui lui
expliquait de l'est du royaume ont
d'accord ça veut rien dire je les ruses
et le thème noir et lourdes ce film
risque d'en rebuter certains pourtant la
classe de neige est empli de cette
tendresse particulière que les enfants
seuls savent nous offrir